big interview off the top here uh and it
regards the topic it's on a lot of
people's minds the the the patience and
lack thereof with these record high gas
prices in this country according to
aaa as of this morning we're at a record
more than five dollars average price
nationally you're looking at it on your
screen 501 that is up nearly two dollars
from last year and it's having a major
impact on people's lives so that
interview i mentioned we're joined now
by energy secretary jennifer granholm
secretary grant home thank you for being
here and good morning to you a tough
time for the country tough time for the
administration here because americans
are pumping gas they're seeing the
numbers go up and up and up simple
question off the top when they're
frustrated seeing that price where
should they place their frustration who
should americans be angry at right now
well they certainly should be angry at
vladimir putin because russia was the
largest and has been one of the largest
exporters of oil and when they invaded
ukraine a number of countries like the
united states canada and others have
said we're not going to buy russian oil
when that happens that pulls millions of
barrels off the global market and that
creates the supply crunch that has
caused the price of gasoline at the pump
to go up a dollar seventy since the
invasion of ukraine so that's number one
number two the president issued a letter
today to refineries um to those who are
doing refining the oil and gas companies
to say
why can't we increase more supply not
just increase supply of production of
crude oil but also increase supply of
gasoline and unfortunately about 80
percent of the lost refining capacity
that came down during cove it happened
uh in 2020 and
and so the president is calling for the
oil and gas companies to increase
refining capacity as well
but madam secretary on that second point
regarding supply and this is confusing
for people me included america has been
the largest producer of oil in the world
for many years now given that fact why
can't we in this country keep prices
down
yeah it's a great question it is because
that oil is traded on a global market so
today the price of oil per barrel is
about 120
people are paying that in
countries all around the world so for
example if you were in in canada you'd
be paying six dollars and 30 cents per
gallon equivalent you'd be paying over
eight dollars per gallon if you lived in
germany if you live in
singapore you'd be paying over nine
dollars a gallon so leaders all across
the globe are calling upon the oil and
gas companies and the producers to
increase supply including in the united
states and to make sure that we can
moderate the supply and demand of course
now we have summer driving season coming
on that is a historically prices go
higher because there's an increase in
demand that puts upward pressure on
prices and now you have europe who has
said that they too are going to ban
russian oil by the end of this year that
will put another upward increase in
prices so globally this is a global
problem it's a problem that the
president is trying to address by
calling upon increases in supply both at
home and globally
madam secretary so if the administration
has already released millions of barrels
from the uh strategic petroleum reserve
but yet the prices are still at record
highs
what other tools do we have what can we
do
yeah
i'm glad you raised that it's a really
important tool i mean the us has the
biggest tool which is that strategic
petroleum reserve and so the president
has released and again called for
another 45 million barrels to be
released he's releasing a million
barrels per day uh and so that tries to
that does moderate a bit so the amount
of oil that was taken off of the global
supply with russia's invasion of ukraine
was about a million a million and a half
barrels um now with rep refining
capacity also being pulled off or having
been pulled offline that's another three
million barrels offline and so the the
strategic petroleum reserve at a million
barrels doesn't quite fill the gap and
so that's why we need to increase supply
and that's why the president is calling
for a meeting with these refiners which
i'll be convening to say what else can
we do by the way the amount that's the
question what else can we do
yeah i mean well the amount of profit
that's being taken right now is
astonishing so for example oil and gas
companies had record profits in the
first quarter 225 percent increase over
what they had in the first quarter of
last year in in march just as one
example in march the price per barrel of
oil was about 100 120 per barrel like it
is today but in march we were paying
4.25 cents per gallon of gasoline today
we're paying over five so there's a 75
cent increase what is going on there so
this is why the president is not
removing any of the tools that he has in
the united states from the table but
recognizing that this is a global uh
matter but he does want to see if we can
increase supply for refineries
madam secretary at what point does this
these prices
what point do they become unsustainable
and two ironically
does this push us closer to renewable
energy
yeah i mean i think the prices are
unsustainable for many people right now
i mean everyday citizens who are on
fixed incomes paying huge amounts of
money that they had not anticipated or
budgeted for just to get to work it's it
is unsustainable for many and
unfortunately there's not a quick fix
however your point about also
accelerating our progress toward clean
energy is very very important we don't
want to be under the thumb of petro
dictators globally or in the united
states we don't want to be at the whim
of the volatility of fossil fuels like
we are right now
and so we want to move to clean energy
and that's why the president and the
bipartisan infrastructure law that was
signed invests a significant amount of
money to move in that direction do you
see this as a silver lining then to the
pain many americans are feeling it'll
accelerate the movement i don't think
there's a silver lining i don't think
there's pain does not have a silver
lining it is painful but i do know that
countries are accelerating um that
toward clean energy i mean europe has
got a whole strategy about moving away
from russian fossil fuels and moving
away from fossil fuels altogether and i
think that's a good thing ultimately but
nobody wants to take any silver lining
or any pleasure at all in what people
are paying at the pump
secretary grant home thank you so much
we appreciate you